bonjour ludovic à travers ces limogeages
qui est visé des responsables locaux
soupçonnés d'avoir collaboré avec la
russie
oui exactement c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
président de lenski qui a annoncé ces
limogeages en citant un article qui lui
permet de révoquer des hauts
fonctionnaires pour incompétence il a
parlé de 650 est une affaire de trahison
et de collaboration il a expliqué que 60
fonctionnaires des services de sécurité
du bureau du procureur général travaille
et je cite contre l'ukraine cela
intervient après l'arrestation samedi
d'un ancien chef régional du sbu donc ce
sont les services secrets ancien chef
régional de ces services accusés d'être
une taupe russe donc on est
effectivement dans un moment de grand
ménage au sein de la haute
administration ukrainienne même si
bacanov le chef des services de sécurité
qui vient d'être limogé est un ami
d'enfance de volodymyr
zelensky une nomination controversée
pour remplacer la procureure générale
celle d'alexis simonenko personnage au
passé trouble proches de l'ancien régime
de victor ianoukovitch
ludovic heures un point à présent sur le
terrain s'il vous plaît notamment un
créateur ce que vous vous trouvez la
russie est en train d'intensifier ses
bombardements sur la région de donetsk
sont peut-être les prémices d'une
opération au south hall très
prochainement
c'est vrai que les bombardements
continus et n'ont pas perdu en intensité
ces derniers jours on a entendu akram à
tort ce que toute la journée d'hier des
bombardements des détonations très
régulièrement ce matin aussi et cette
nuit ça nous a réveillés vers 4 heures
du matin parce que c'était très fort il
y en a eu trois essais tombés pas très
loin le maire de la de la ville de crem
a tort qui a confirmé qu'une zone
industrielle avaient été visés par des
tirs de systèmes de lanceurs de
roquettes multiples et c'était le bruit
était vraiment très impressionnant donc
objectivement les bombardements n'ont
pas perdu en intensité est ce que c'est
pour autant le signe qu'une opération
terrestre va nécessairement reprendre
c'est pas certain il ya d'autres signes
qui semble indiquer qu'une nouvelle
opération terrestre est sur le point de
commencer c'est ce que par exemple le
ministre russe de la défense
a donné pour instruction de faire à ses
troupes mais quand on parle aux soldats
ukrainien ici dans l'est de l'ukraine
dans le donbass ils nous disent que plus
il ya de bombardements à distance des
russes et parfois sur des zones qui sont
très loin des combats plus indique qu'en
réalité ils sont impuissants au niveau
du front et si des opérations terrestres
devait avoir lieu le fait de tirer sur
des villes qui sont très loin du front
n'aurait pas grand chose à voir ce qu'il
nous dit c'est quand il essaye d'avancer
et là en l'occurrence ça serait verse la
violence que civière sq ou encore bach
moutain des villes qui sont pas civière
ce que c'est sur le front ou d'autres
qui sont très proches du front ils
enverraient des tirs au mortier mais on
pourrait pas vraiment les entendre delà
de là où nous sommes de là où nous
sommes actuellement ils enverraient des
tanks et puis après il enverrait les
fantassins en rangée mais mais le fait
de tirer sur des villes très loin de ce
front n'est pas un si nécessaire
nécessairement avant coureur d'une telle
intervention